these kids are cutting a shallow channel
to lay a cable around the lawn which
they call their green classroom and
they've installed solar panels on the
roof of the carport to power an
emissions-free lawnmower
Tobias Whitaker and his schoolmates make
up the Environmental Action Group at
their High School in the town of park in
the cable in the ground acts as a
boundary for the robot lawnmower when it
reaches the cable it turns around and
then it mows some more teachers are also
involved in the project Babolat curt
teaches biology and chemistry she wants
her students to appreciate the
importance of protecting the environment
she works in the green class from even
during her free time I want to see my
students do things at home that we teach
them here like not throwing things away
where they shouldn't were lighting
bonfires in their gardens or driving
cars that are inefficient and pollute a
lot they need to learn how to conserve
resources Hannes fudge a former student
is now an energy consultant to the local
authorities he's helping design the
school's solar power system there's a
whole array on the roof it's
environmentally friendly and cuts energy
costs it provides more than enough
electricity for the school's own use
the rest it feeds into the grid this
display tracks the operation of the
solar plant not every school is so
engaged in environmental activism
harness is pleased to see so much
commitment here it's really important
that the people at a school take a
project like this seriously and
appreciate its significance it's not
just about money here they get it and
it's led to more small projects like the
one with a lawn mower or the energy game
which is about to be launched it
involves an app designed to encourage
pupils and teachers to
turn off the lights when they're not
needed every time you scan one of these
QR codes you get a point
whoever gets the most is the champion
energy saver energy from AIESEC quasi
I'm in the Fisker and the champ will get
a prize the idea is for youngsters to
learn to think ecologically and to care
about the future of the planet geography
is one subject where many of the key
themes come together
global warming means the polar bears at
the North Pole
and the Penguins are losing their
habitats in geography we learned that
the RLC is shrinking and it's going to
disappear one day when Road Rash mileage
garden might garnish my access to out in
the green classroom the kids have been
working for two hours now
the lawnmower is going to figure in a
physics class the kids can monitor the
level of the battery that stores the
electricity generated in the three solar
panels on the carport roof and thus also
the range of the lawnmower if they have
a lawn to mow at home they might now
suggest their parents install solar
panels too so they don't have to get the
power out of the socket join an
interesting masters tech daughter the
cable is almost laid a score of pupils
and former pupils have been working hard
here soon the system will be ready and
the robot can get to work so everyone
can see that
eco-friendly technology is worthwhile
and even fun